here comes james after the steal by
schroeder and the
lakers will have it and kcp finds the
cutting davis
who is shoved from behind by devin
booker
you can tell right there as anthony
davis cut to the basket was fouled and
just not moving as well as he'd like a
little gingerly right there and
i think devin booker fouled him you can
see him grimacing right there
uncomfortable in pain and certainly out
here giving it his all but he has not
really touched the ball or been engaged
yet offensively
as he's struggling to get up down down
the court here on defense
bridges with the rebound has the ball
now he's got the uh defensive assignment
davis does the bridges and they switch
and here's paul
and he's going to attack he understands
right now he smells blood in the water
the shifty paul booker
quickly blitzed ayton inside good
defense by gasal
nice defense by the lakers who had the
number one rating defensively most of
the regular season and good defense
right there the lakers
obviously accustomed to switching
anthony davis struggling but was able to
slide his feet there against chris paul
and
the shot clock violation or turnover
there excuse me
something to watch here early as dave is
giving it his all
trying to help his team on the verge of
being
defeated possibly by these sons
and right there of course with lebron
james transition defensive
davis i'm not sure he's going to be able
to continue
it's the left groin and down he goes
and it lasted all five and a half
minutes
[Applause]
you saw it in the first time you ran up
the floor you looked at me and said uh
you kind of were shaking your heads it's
just not there
yeah you know you have 20 minutes before
the game to get ready and here he is
trying to defend booker and just cannot
move
all the lateral movements and jumping
twisting and turning required to play
this game of basketball
and when you have a growing injury you
know it's just
it's not going to allow you to be at
your best so he's got he's got the
strain left groin
it happened uh in game three the lakers
when he hyper extended his left knee in
that game three win
he played game four but aggravated the
injury
and as he was telling the press the
interconnected nature of muscles and
joints and the leg
affected other areas like his groin well
no question i mean when you have an
injury you overcompensate sometimes and
that can lead to another injury
someplace else
which may have played a role in his
groin injury occurring kyle kuzma has
taken his place
out goes davis lasting five and a half
minutes and the lakers now are down a
starter they made a change with gasol
the pass is high
and a foul is called inside juggle it's
off of phoenix lakers have it 13 to fire
and i know harold missed that shot right
there but i like the play there harold
had a mismatch booker on him
his energy his activity and his ability
to score in that low post
so important for this team is dave is
struggling there on the sidelines
wanting to be out there and
obviously there's been a lot of chatter
about him and wanting to play
and you know i i don't feel he had any
business being out there i'm sure he's
heard a lot of the noise out there and
gave it a valiant try but there's an old
adage in sports you're either hurt
or you're injured and when you're hurt
you play and when you're injured
you sit and clearly he's injured
we know lebron's not 100 the ankle's
still a concern
it's kuzma across the lane a running
hook and down it goes
kyle kuzma scores for the first time
tonight